Let's go to your voicemails, (219)-2DAVIDP is our voicemail number.
Here's a voicemail that came in that I found interesting to say the least.
Yes, David Pakman, I believe that you and Don Lemon should be fired.
You both are racist,
you both are pinheads.
You only want to focus on domestic terrorism that is caused by white males. You ignore the
crimes of all races,
you ignore like the Florida shooting. There was a serial killer just shooting random people in Florida about a year ago. There's numerous
many vicious crimes that can be put under domestic terrorism and you and Don Lemon
are totally idiots for just focusing on a few
mass shootings
in recent days because of the midterm elections. You you two are complete morons,
are complete idiots and both of you should be dismissed from your jobs
as
CNN fake news analysts.
Right
So I have nothing to do with CNN first of all
and I don't know what Don Lemon has to do with me and of course
anecdotally pointing out that once a guy shot people in Florida
doesn't change the fact that the overwhelming majority of domestic terrorism is committed by the right. As far as firing me, who's gonna fire me?
I'm in charge here Troy and I know that that bothers you but I am in charge here
so there's nobody who can fire me
other than every single member of the audience saying we're not gonna listen anymore or watch anymore, which would be a de facto firing.
But I don't know who you're hoping is going to fire me. We have a great bonus show for you today
we'll talk about how the Republican house fund is not helping Steve King because of his
association with white supremacists, this is good.
We'll talk about Native Americans fighting back against a North Dakota voter ID law and we will talk about the
GoFundMe campaigns for Christine Blasi Ford. There's actually an interesting story
related to those GoFundMe campaigns and we're gonna deal with that on today's bonus show.
Sign up for membership at www.joinpacman.com,
you can also get access to the bonus show by making a $5 or greater a month pledge,
should say a $5 a month or greater pledge on
Patreon at patreon.com/davidpakmanshow. Two ways to get the bonus show.
You will love the bonus show either way and I look forward to speaking to you then.